ANA RITA PIRES: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been
learning about the properties
of determinants.
To remember, there were
three main properties,
and then seven more that
fall out of those three.
I'll tell you what
these three were.
The first one was the
determinant of the identity
matrix is always equal to 1.
If you switch two
rows in a matrix,
the determinant switches sign.
And the determinant
is a function
of each-- it's a linear
function of each row separately.
And there's seven more.
We'll use them here.
Today's problem is about finding
the determinants of matrices
by using these properties.
So here you have four matrices.
A has lots of 100's,
200's, and 300's numbers.
B is called a
Vandermonde matrix.
It has a very nice structure
with 1's, and then a, b, c;
a squared, b squared, c squared.
It can be bigger,
and you'll just
have cubes and more
letters down here.
C is given by the
product of these two,
and D is this matrix.
Good luck.
Hit pause, work on them, and
when you're ready, come back
and I'll show you how I did it.
Did you get some?
OK, let's do it.
Starting with matrix A. I
have lots of big numbers.
I suggest that we do a
little bit of elimination,
because as you know,
doing elimination steps,
except for permuting
rows, doesn't change
the determinant of the matrix.
So let's do determinant of A
is equal to-- 101, 201, 301.
Then if I subtract off the
first row from the second one,
I'll get 1, 1, 1, which
is very convenient.
And actually, if you
subtract the second row
from the third one,
you'll get 1, 1, 1.
Here's the property
of the determinant:
if you have two equal
rows on your matrix,
the determinant is
automatically equal to zero.
All right.
All done with one of them.
Let's work on the second one.
The determinant of B. Well,
let's try elimination again.
1, a, a squared.
1 minus 1 is 0, b minus a,
and b squared minus a squared.
b squared minus a squared--
let me factor that
into b minus a, b plus
a, which will be very
convenient in the next step.
And then I'm going to
subtract the first row again
from the third one.
I'll get 0, c minus a.
And again, I'll get c
squared minus a squared, c
minus a, c plus a.
Let's use that third property
that was the determinant
is linear on each
row separately.
So what I'm going to do is,
see this factor of b minus a?
It shows up in every
entry of this row.
Well it's a 0, so it's the
zero multiple of b minus a.
So I'm going to pull out
this factor of b minus a,
and this row is going to
become 0, 1, b plus a.
I will also, in the same
step, do the same thing
with the third row.
I'll pull out a
factor of c minus a,
and it will become
0, 1, c plus a.
Here's one factor
from the second row.
Another factor
from the third row.
And 1, a, a squared.
0, 1, b plus a.
0, 1, c plus a.
Now what?
Well remember,
you know how to do
the determinant of upper
triangular matrices
because all that you do
is multiply the pivots.
This is almost upper triangular,
except there's a 1 over here.
So let's do another
elimination step.
b minus a, c minus a.
1, a, a squared; 0, 1, b
plus a; 0, 0, c plus a minus
b plus a is c minus b.
So the determinant of this
matrix is now 1 times 1 times
c minus b.
So we get b minus a,
c minus a, c minus b,
which has a really nice formula.
This is called the
Vandermonde determinant.
It's always like this, even if
your matrix is bigger than 3
by 3, if it's 4 by 4, or
5 by 5 and so on, you just
have more differences
of all the letters
that show up in your matrix.
On to matrix number 3.
C equals [1, 2, 3] [1, -4, 5].
How did you get the
determinant for this one?
Well remember, this
is a rank one matrix
because it's a column
vector times a row vector.
So if you write out what
the matrix is it'll be a 3
by 3 matrix where we can
think about it this way.
The first row will be
1 times [1, -4, 5].
The second row will be
2 times those numbers.
And the third row will be
three times those numbers.
So all the rows are going
to be linearly dependent,
or another way of saying
the matrix is singular.
When the matrix is
singular, the determinant
is always equal to 0.
That's also one
of the properties.
C is 0.
Onto the next matrix.
Last one.
D is equal to 0, 0, 0.
1, -1, 3, -3, 4, -4.
Maybe you didn't get that from
just looking at the matrix
the first time, but did you
see how I wrote it down?
It has 0's down the diagonal.
And then for each entry,
I have minus that entry.
That means that this
matrix is skew symmetric.
What that means is if
you do D transpose,
it will not be
equal to D, but it
will be equal to minus D. D
transpose is equal to minus D.
Now, what does this give
us for a determinant?
Well if these two matrices
are the same matrix,
this determinant is equal
to that determinant.
One of the properties
is that the determinant
of a transpose of the matrix
is equal to the determinant
of the original matrix.
How about this side?
Well, first temptation
would be to just write that.
Is that always true?
No.
The determinant is linear
on each row separately.
That means that you can't
pull out the factor that
is multiplying the matrix.
You have to pull it out once
for each row of the matrix.
So what I should
have written was
-1, that's my factor, minus.
How many rows do I have?
One, two, three.
Pull it out once for each row.
Times the determinant of D. Well
fortunately, -1 to the third
is simply equal to -1.
So here we go.
It was correct, in fact.
We have determinant of D is
equal to minus determinant
of D. What is the
only number that
is equal to minus that number?
0.
Determinant of D is
equal to 0 again.
Let me ask you
one last question.
Is it true that all skew
symmetric matrices have
the determinant equal to 0?
It was true for this one.
Is it true in every case?
Well, the key factor
here was that I
had -1 to the third power
and I got a minus sign here,
determinant of D is equal
to minus determinant of D.
What if this number had
been an even number?
Then I would just have
the determinant of D
is equal minus 1 to an
even number, D. That's 1.
So I would have determinant of
D is equal to determinant of D.
There's nothing I can
say about that number.
It can be your favorite
number, not necessarily 0.
All right.
We're done for today.
Thank you.